je suis vola ans pauline l'empereur
écraser ces autrichiens
ils seront entraînés
vous maîtrisez tous les jours je vous le
promets
des cris ou pas c'est un séducteur voilà
la vérité un séducteur
[Musique]
qu'est ce qui vous est arrivé il ya
trois ans vous êtes parti pour loterie
coline est mariée et mère de deux
enfants est pour elle vous est mort et
enterré je le rassure sur le chemin même
après le temps lui écrire alors je les
fais moi voilà je me suis fait passer
pour vous et je l'écris quelques lettres
dans la dernière je vous ai foot foot
l'attention de ville cette part en héros
ce serait dommage et où les chez nous ah
oui le vix les revenus
nous avions un accord c'est de lier
partir vous êtes fous c'est ça vous avez
perdu la raison
voici 2 face à 2000 anglais qui chargent
dans ma direction et ne sont plus qu'à
100 m on doit se posera des tombes et la
[Musique]
cavalerie est arrivé c'est à la chute
c'est nul je vous l'accordé mais c'est
de ma vie et on l'a choisie par les
piètres imposture ne tiendra pas
toujours elisabeth si je tombe vous
tombez avec moi c'est un peu fatigué je
vais me reposer dans une chambre avec la
dernière en vue de couloir bonsoir
non pardon je tendais quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai vu une autre fois peut-être
non vous êtes en train de dénaturer mon
oeuvre
le capitaine que je crée des formes
subtiles ailleurs je ne suis rien ici je
suis le capitaine de ville arrêtez vous
avez fait vous du spa je n'ai jamais
compté 11
[Musique]